Whether Pixar's short-term memory loss or the saying "he owns
Golden fish brain "we are constantly told that fish are simple and have weak memories
But are they more complex than we think?
This is the illusion of rotating snakes - when you move your eyes, the snakes will appear to be moving
In a circle but in fact the picture is static. It turns out that fish sees this illusion
In a similar way to you and me. Although the fish is different from wild vertebrates, it has since 450 million
One year, the two developed a vision similar to hunting, escaping predators and avoiding collisions.
The researchers hypothesized that we see the same motor illusion as a result of "evolution
Convergent "organism, where non-living organisms that are associated with each other develop independently similar traits
As a result of their need to adapt to a similar environment.
Which of these red circles is the largest? Often your eyes will tell you that they are falling
On the right, the fish will think so too. But they turned out to be the same size.
In a study at the Sprintfins' Redtail, the fish were trained to distinguish between the tablets
Different sizes and preference for larger disks. And when they display similar illusion they choose
The largest is imaginary.
What about the duration of attention? In a special report they found that the length of human attention
Less than 12 seconds in 2000, to 8 seconds today. Our use of the Internet
The instruments explain that he plays a role but - whatever - the goldfish has 9 seconds duration
Attention, beyond my human rights
When it comes to forgetting, a study done using African tilapia gave fish a diet as a reward
A certain area of ​​the aquarium for 3 consecutive days. Then they gave the fish 12 days
Take a break before starting to re-apply in the aquarium. Using the motion tracking software
Tilapia showed a special preference for the area in the basin where
They previously received the reward. Studies have also shown that golden fish can remember things
At least for 3 months; distinguish between shapes, colors, sounds, and even discrimination
The labyrinths. Above all, the golden fish can identify its owner. In the end, the fish showed
They have a good memory for them - after all they need to remember prey and avoid predators
And also avoid our traps after they were caught in the past.
But when it comes to pain we really disagree with fish. When you hurt
Yourself, your body has sensory receptors called "nussi sputose" that send signals to the cortex where sensation
The pain is treated there. But a lot of fish lacks sensory receptors and all the fish lacks cortex, so this is pain
Not tested the same way.
When "Finding Nemo" was published, hundreds of fish were released
But in fact these fish often die because of a blow or exposure to fresh water. In addition to that
Researchers are concerned that the launch of "cyclical finding" will further decrease the population of aquariums
Where many people would like to take the Royal Blue Tang as a pet
So we decided to do a video of 8 other amazing marine animals in "AsapTHOUGHT", where we visited
Aquarium for personal inspection. Our lakes and oceans are full of some beautiful wildlife
So check the link below
And subscribe to more weekly scientific videos